the movie starts in the year 1962 on an
italian ocean liner named grotza a
singer named francesca is entertaining
the guests who enjoy the night dancing
with their loved ones amidst the crowd a
little girl named katie sits alone
because she doesn't have a partner to
dance with the captain of the ship
notices this and brings her to the floor
the lively party quickly turns into a
dreadful one when an unknown hand lifts
a lever that tightens a wire cord the
wire then snaps and whips across the
dance floor bisecting the passengers and
crew their bodies thump on the ground
one after another creating a bloodbath
the only person left alive on the dance
floor is katie since the wire couldn't
get her because of her height the scene
cuts 40 years later to the future a
salvage crew of six people is rescuing a
random vessel from the sea captain
murphy leads his team and successfully
brings the ship to the shore the group
then goes to a pub to celebrate where
they are approached by an old
acquaintance named jack jack also works
in the marine business and has heard
about a ghost ship from 1962.
rumor has it that the ship contains a
chest of gold that has been missing for
half a century the person who brings the
ship to the shore gets to claim whatever
is in it this sparks the crew's interest
and they set off to look for the ship on
their salvage tug the next day after a
few hours long trip they reach the
destination but the tracker shows no
ships around the area they check if it
is working properly and come to the
conclusion that the report was fake just
when they are about to turn around they
get a view of a massive commercial ship
in front of them their boat slams into
the ship but luckily the impact is not
damaging after dwelling on who gets to
go inside first jack and a crewmate
greer stay behind while the other four
enter the ship only seconds after their
arrival the group starts experiencing
paranormal activities first they hear
random noises then they see things
moving through the dark corners they
blame it on the wind and keep moving but
behind them a scrabble moves on its own
and forms the words welcome aboard i
call [ __ ] no one ever gets a hand
that good in scrabble when they are on
the upper deck one of the crew members
named munder falls into a hole but he is
saved by the only woman in the group
maureen as she tries pulling him up the
little girl katie suddenly appears in
the background she disappears within
seconds not giving maureen a chance to
comprehend whether she was real the
incident makes her feel uneasy but she
doesn't tell anyone about it a little
further the group discovers a digital
watch on the floor since these kinds of
watches were not a thing in 1962 they
theorized that someone has been on the
ship before them after that the captain
decides to continue the search the next
day since the ship is massive when
maureen is alone at night jack
approaches her he senses that she is
tense after saving munder earlier upon
finding out about the little girl jack
goes quiet for a few seconds he seems to
know something but doesn't show it on
the outside instead he suggests maureen
sleep for some more hours to get rid of
the hallucinations the next day the crew
sits down to plan their next move they
have discovered that the ship is slowly
sinking because of a damage to its base
they decide to stay in the water for
three days to fix it and then return to
shore with the entire ship without
wasting much time they continue their
respective jobs on the different parts
of the ship meanwhile maureen explores
it and reaches the swimming pool area
she notices bullet marks on the wall
which is strange because they were told
that all passengers died of drowning
while trying to climb out of the pool
she again comes face to face with katie
startled she falls off the ladder and
starts bleeding from her head however
when she looks back up jack is standing
in the place where katie was seconds ago
the two walk away without noticing that
marine's blood is disappearing from the
pool soon the bullet holes start oozing
out blood and the entire pool is filled
with it ghosts don't have blood after
that jack and maureen explore the
laundry room and find another door that
was not in the ship's blueprint upon
opening it they are pushed by a force of
water which also brings mutilated
corpses out of the locked room both jack
and marine panic and try to run away
however the door they came through locks
on its own leaving them no option but to
go further into the ship in the meantime
captain murphy ends up in the captain's
lounge he finds an opened bottle of
alcohol but while trying to take a sip
he sees the ship's actual captain in the
mirror the glass drops and shatters as
murphy runs away in fear unaware of the
paranormal activities greer is minding
his own business when he hears someone
singing it is francesca the same
performer who was entertaining the
passengers on board in 1962. greer looks
for the source of the sound but gives up
after a while what he doesn't know is
that the woman is watching him walk away
from behind him somewhere else jack and
maureen come across a chest filled with
blocks of gold it is worth millions of
dollars that everyone in the crew can
take home they excitedly gather everyone
and show them the treasure now they no
longer need to repair the ship and can
return home with just the treasure in
the following scene everyone is loading
the gold into their boat the mechanic
santos is cleaning the engines so they
would be ready when they decide to leave
behind him someone deliberately leaks
propane from a cylinder which causes an
explosion it results in santos's death
and the boat's destruction everyone is
shocked and saddened by the unexpected
death moreover now they are stuck on the
ship until they managed to repair it
right before the explosion maureen had
seen katie again it was as if she was
trying to warn maureen about the
explosion but was stopped by someone
this is enough reason for marine to look
into who katie is she goes through the
passenger registry and finds out her
room number on walking to the room
maureen screams in shock it turns out
that katie died of hanging as her
decomposed corpse is still hung from the
ceiling after composing herself maureen
comes closer and takes a necklace off
katie's corpse her spirit appears in the
room and asks for the necklace maureen
tries handing it to her but it goes
right through her palm it is now clear
to her that the little girl is not a
human took her long enough in the
kitchen two crew members find fresh
meals they do not question it before
devouring half of the food initially it
tastes amazing but after a while they
smell a horrible scent unchecking they
see that the food has turned into
maggots both of them panic and start
vomiting in disgust then there is greer
who is in the ballroom everything is
normal until all of a sudden the place
transforms into how it looked before the
wreckage the guests surround him and act
like they are at a typical party
moreover francesca seems to have extra
interest in him she flirts with the guy
and manipulates him into kissing her
even though he has a fiance waiting for
him at home after the kiss he is already
too deep to back out francesca starts
undressing while he follows her hoping
to end up in her room but instead he
falls off a high platform and dies this
is a metaphor for where cheating gets
you in life the beautiful woman then
shows her real deformed face in the
meantime murphy is in the captain's room
when suddenly a bottle of alcohol starts
moving on its own he looks at it closely
then finds the ship's captain sitting in
front of him the man offers murphy some
alcohol much to his disbelief the
captain is not here to hurt him but to
have a chat he tells murphy about a lost
ship named lorelai 40 years ago when
everything came down the lorelei ship
was found by grazza the ship they're on
right now but two days after finding the
lost ship grotza also disappeared with
that being said murphy has handed a
picture that leaves him in shock
meanwhile katie and maureen are also
chatting in her room the little girl
reveals that everyone who died on the
ship 40 years ago has been trapped here
ever since they cannot go to heaven
because someone powerful is binding them
to the ship now the only way they can be
released is if the ship is destroyed
before katie explains who the powerful
person is the walls in the room start
changing colors she panics and orders
maureen to run away before disappearing
herself back in the swimming pool area
murphy is looking for the rest of the
crew he has finally found out the truth
about the ship's disappearance and wants
to return to the shore as soon as
possible but on the way he is attacked
by several santos the guy who died in
the explosion earlier the hallucination
seems so real that when maureen
approaches him murphy thinks she is also
the ghost of santos he attacks her and
does everything he can to end her life
maureen somehow manages to stab him in
the feet and save herself a while later
jack arrives and knocks murphy out for
their own safety they put him in a
drained fish tank and lock him inside by
now the group doesn't care about the
gold and just wants to return to land
they continue fixing the ship for the
next few hours and finally get it done
since greer has still not returned from
the lounge area everyone is worried
while the guys do some last minute
checking marine goes to look for him she
yet again comes across katie who shows
her greer's dead body this time the girl
is adamant about showing maureen
everything that happened on the ship 40
years ago she touches marine and brings
her to the past the ship is lively with
people's chatter and laughs but what
they do not know is that the co-captain
has convinced the entire crew to kill
everyone on board for the gold they
found earlier the cooks mixed rat poison
with the food which killed the majority
of the people then the dance floor
massacre followed the remaining
survivors were shot dead in the pool
poor katie was dragged into her room and
hanged to death at last the crew members
ran to the treasure and started grabbing
whatever they could but the co-captain
didn't allow that either joining hands
with francesca he shot every single one
of them at last the two of them were
left before francesca betrayed him and
shot him in the head it turned out her
actual lover is a different man who was
also the mastermind behind the entire
massacre after killing hundreds of
people they shared a passionate kiss but
the surprises did not end there the man
killed francesca by releasing a hook
that slashed into her neck and hooked
her damn the 2000s were gruesome in the
end the man is revealed to be none other
than jack he is a demonic spirit of a
dead sinner his job is to make people
sin and then kill them to bring their
souls to hell everything makes sense to
marine now because jack was the one who
told them about the ship in the first
place he also appeared out of nowhere
when marines saw katie in the pool
moreover he has been asking her to
forget about katie every time she told
him about her maureen suddenly remembers
murphy but when she reaches him he has
already drowned and died in the aquarium
she quickly goes to the others to warn
them of the murderer on board munder is
scuba diving in the flooded engine room
to fix something she wants to follow him
but the pipes fill with blood ghost
blood indicating that he has also died
it turns out that someone pulled him
into the gears and ground him to death
now the only two people left are marine
and the last crew member named dodge she
asks him to keep an eye out for jack
while she places explosives on the ship
but when dodge and jack are alone jack
plays games with his head and starts a
fight in a fit of rage dodge shoots him
and assumes that he is dead he then goes
to maureen who has just finished setting
the explosives he tells her he killed
jack and that they can start a life
together using the gold maureen thinks
about it for a second and then asks him
why he hasn't inquired about munder who
still hasn't been found it is then
revealed that the person is actually
jack who was trying to make maureen sin
as long as this boat remains the souls
will never be let free jack knows that
maureen is a good person so he offers to
spare her life in exchange for her not
interfering with his rules but in
response maureen detonates the
explosives jack and the entire ship are
blown into pieces while marine jumps off
and saves her life she is underwater
struggling to find a way out when katie
comes to her rescue finally all the
souls who died on the ship are let free
the next morning a cruise ship finds
maureen floating on a box and she is
rescued as she is being taken away in an
ambulance she notices a crate of gold
being loaded onto a cruise ship jack has
somehow been resurrected and is planning
to continue the cycle of sin the movie
ends as maureen screams and the
ambulance door closes subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching